Yeah.
It looked like you tension and fucking Floyd was fixed.
What do you think is real?
100% Oh Joe,
you want to watch again?
Should we can,
why do you think it was fixed at you?
Come on.
Do you watch it?
Yeah,
I just think of some bullshit.
No,
it was a,
a guy who's legitimate,
hundred and 55 pound man who is fighting.
You see techy crying and rolling around on the ground due to fights at one 26 it
doesn't make any sense.
Never had a professional boxing match.
How crazy is this fighting against the greatest boxer?
Listening to what you're saying.
So small and fixed intentions.
They're fucking poster boy.
Yeah.
And they're like,
yeah,
here's Floyd Mayweather,
dude.
I don't think they thought he was going to knock them out.
Really tensions a beast,
man.
I mean easily seen them,
but when it comes to,
I have,
but when it comes to boxing,
I understand that.
But they were really thinking he could hit him.
This was the thought was that tension is really a striking genius.
Have you never seen him?
So it's Conor McGregor.
Well,
but no,
no,
but it's different.
Tension is faster.
It's smaller.
I mean he moves like a lightning bolt and in Japan,
the,
the fact that this kid's only like 18 or 19 years old,
crazy and been fucking people up,
including knocking out world boy Thai champions.
So they threw him to the wolves real early on.
Okay,
let's watch this and tell me,
tell me why you think this is fake.
I see a dude who is so much smaller than Floyd.
Look how little he is way smaller.
He's way smaller.
Floyd is not even mess around.
He's not remotely nervous.
This kid is,
uh,
I mean,
I remember if he was deployed laughing no matter he'd even do this to Connor,
but this a cookbook.
Of course Connor can knock him out this Katana,
check him out.
He's supposed to be the next big thing too.
He's a great kick boxer,
but he's not kickboxing.
He's boxing.
You're not gonna out box Floyd Mayweather when you've never had a professional
boxing match.
At least I don't think he has.
He's had a lot of kickboxing though.
And in kickboxing he's fucking amazing.
But he's also amazing against guys that are 126 pounds,
so 18 to look how small he is compared to Floyd.
Floyd is tiny and Floyd.
Look how easily Floyd blocks those punches and he's not feeling any danger,
so he's just ties to put it on this kid.
He's walking him down.
He's walking him down looking for an opening.
This is the first round.
Just weights.
Boom.
He cracks him.
Why would you ask him that?
He just got was a crack.
You don't think back it up.
Bag of that shit up.
Jack it up.
Let's watch it again dude.
He cracked him.
Watch this right there.
Here it goes.
Let it roll from here.
You get some in his corner.
He hit him with a left hook to the temple.
You don't see that left hook to the temple.
Watch one or time pink right there.
Thank you.
He fucking cracked a dude who's a legit 30 pounds lighter than him here on the
temple and drop to how you watched the crack.
You just watched it to doubt.
It's a,
that is a fear flying back.
That is a full on left took.
First of all,
there was a stumble in there as well,
but he hit him,
see the stumble after he got robbed.
That's a tough one.
No,
I don't see that.
It's not tough at all.
The kid gets up,
he got wobbled,
they give him a standing count.
He looks nervous as fuck.
He looks over,
they see sticking to the smash.
Your fucking crazy and now Floyd moves in and the kids even trying to fire back.
He's just not good enough.
Man.
Floyd standard right in front of him with his fucking hands up.
The kid's got no chance.
He's much smaller.
No experience against the guy as good as Floyd and Floyd's walking him down with
his head.
This is real,
man.
This is real.
That kid's trying to hurt him.
He just can't do it.
He's fighting the best ever and then boom,
Cod Zion was,
that was real,
that fuck.
All of it's really the first one.
They look you as you should know.
We've all seen guys get hit with shit that didn't look like much and they go
down.
We've all seen it.
We've all seen guys get touched on the Chin and they fall down.
Let you don't Floyd,
look at this.
Do you remember Travis Luder versus Marvin Eastman?
You remember that?
A lot of people said that was fixed.
They like,
that's fake.
No one gets hit with a punch like that.
No,
no.
Sometimes you come into a fight compromised.
Look,
this is 100% legit one,
two right on the fucking head,
and he falls down.
Dude,
this is 100% legit fight.
This kid got fucked up by the best boxer of all chassis.
They might say 126 tiny.
None of this made any sense in the first place,
but narrow sense,
but you gotta admit that's a real fight.
Delek pretty legit.
Like it's real.
That's a real God.
That first one,
that first one is questionable.
The next two were great.
It was a questionable lump.
Just same for the [inaudible].
For my first one,
it looked questionable to me.
If you watch the whole thing play out in slow motion,
what happens is you see a left hook and then you see a stumble and Floyd moves
in and their legs tangled up a little bit,
and then Floyd hits him with a right hand when he's on his way down.
Floyd,
fuck that dude.
Up.